Speaker 1: The other person who is at great
risk of of a lawsuit related to all of these
bogus election claims is the man himself,
Donald Trump.
Been talking about the Dominion lawsuit, and
it looks like Donald Trump is not going to
possibly remain unscathed from the the multibillion
dollar set of lawsuits that have gone out.
The insiders reporting that Dominion lawyer
says the voting technology company is still
exploring whether to sue Trump over election
lies.
Dominion Voting Systems is still weighing
whether to bring a defamation lawsuit against
former President Donald Trump over election
conspiracy theories.
An attorney for the company said Tuesday Dominion
continues to take an evidence based approach
to investigating other participants in the
campaign of lies dating all the way back to
last November, attorney Steven Shackelford
told Inciter at a press conference.
The election technology company filed three
lawsuits Tuesday morning against the right
wing organizations, One America News and Newsmax.
It has also sued two employees of OCN, as
well as former Overstock CEO Patrick Byrne.
Well, let me tell you, it seems as though
something Donald Trump will be very keen on,
if you remember his support of opening up
our libel laws, whatever that means, so we
can sue journalists and make a lot of money.
Remember this moment?
Speaker 2: And one of the things I'm going
to do, and this is only going to make it tougher
for me and I've never said this before, but
one of the things I'm going to do if I win
and I hope I do and we're certainly leading.
Is I'm going to open up our libel laws, so
when they write purposely negative and horrible
and false articles, we can sue them and win
lots of money.
We're going to open up those libel laws so
that when The New York Times writes a hit
piece, which is a total disgrace, or when
The Washington Post, which is there for other
reasons, writes a hit piece, we can sue them
and win money instead of having no chance
of winning because they're totally protected.
You see, with me, they're not protected because
I'm not like other people, but I'm not taking
money.
I'm not taking their money.
So we're going to open up those libel laws,
folks, and we're going to have people sue
you like you never get sued before
Speaker 1: and make a lot of money because,
again, that's the that's the mission of Donald
Trump.
That's the M.O.
That's the impetus for Donald Trump's existence
is to make a lot of money.
And to create general chaos in his wake.
It wasn't just on the campaign trail in 2016,
though, that he said these things even when
he was actually president of the United States
sitting in the White House, he was committed
to violating the United States Constitution,
the First Amendment and our right to free
speech that the government shall make no law.
Abridging the free press, remember this moment
Speaker 2: on a separate front, we are going
to take a strong look at our country's libel
laws so that when somebody says something
that is false and defamatory about someone,
that person will have meaningful recourse
in our courts.
If somebody says something that's totally
false and knowingly false, that the person
that has been abused, defamed, libeled will
have meaningful recourse.
Our current libel laws are a sham and a disgrace
and do not represent American values or American
fairness.
So we're going to take a strong look at that.
We want fairness.
You can't say things that are false, knowingly
false, and be able to smile as money pours
into your bank account.
We're going to take a very, very strong look
at that.
And I think what the American people want
to see is fairness.
Speaker 1: So, again, Donald Trump wants to
take a strong look at our libel laws because,
you know, by his own account, you can't say
things that are knowingly false.
You just can't do it.
It would be a beautiful, poetic irony, poetic
justice, if Donald Trump was to fall underfoot,
to be sued for hundreds of millions of dollars,
depleting any money that he actually does
have.
Over this, after all of the bluster, after
all of the nonsense about opening up the libel
laws, if he was to fall prey to a defamation
suit where he was found guilty and have to
pay damages, because let me tell you, Dominion
ain't playing around.
And Donald Trump is at risk here and he is
justifiably at risk because he has damaged
our union in an attempt to overturn an election,
in an attempt to overthrow the very government
under which we live.
Through his insurrection.
His his whipping up of his his followers into
a frenzy where they wanted to assassinate
the vice president of the United States, they
erected the the hangman's Gallow on the lawn
of the Capitol.
All of these images that should stick in your
mind because it is reprehensible behavior.
And if in some way there could be some justice,
justice meted out via a lawsuit, even a civil
one, that would be good.